le comptable a trouvé sa mort d'une
gifle c'est pourtant bien la route de
les six gars une fille blonde la moitié
avoir un boîtier après que me répond un
débit la grippe c'est quoi la vie tu
sais le crooner harry potter
rester là-bas pour l'assurer muté à
l'etrat
[Musique]
non non non non on va faire la plume à
la plume c'est la clé si tu fermes les
yeux et que tu penses que tu vois quoi
essayer choix coustel sur une autre vie
j'aurai tout sourire
un joli c'est cliché mais personne pour
l'entendre
est-ce qu'elle existe encore j'suis pas
vanessa paradis joey starr merci d'être
là on est à cannes
franchement dans un cadre magnifique à
une demi-heure jouez vous étiez dans la
piscine c'est ça le festival de cannes
c'est allier plaisir et en même temps
présenté des films moi il ya toujours un
mec qui marche à côté de moi mon alter
ego donc je passe de l'un à l'autre
donc c'est pas moi qui suis allé me
gêner cielo tracé quelqu'un d'autre au
caire bah c'est tellement une chance est
là le présentait chimie cpie nous tous
les clichés on a tourné il ya deux ans
s'est pas revu depuis
donc on se retrouve on est assez content
vous avez hâte de présenter le film au
public
oui oui bah ouais en fait contrairement
à vanessa moi je n'ai vu il ya
trois-quatre jours je tiens à préciser
que le butin kerven et ramzy bedia ne
l'ont pas vu et prétend ils font des
intervalles y ait très envie de balancer
sa tresse en émoi de la délation c'est
mon dada mais non moi tout côté
protocolaire d'ici m'échappe un peu mais
juste au moment où à moins que tu jettes
le truc quoi j'aurais comment ce qu'on
entend dans l'univers de samada chétrite
shamal il raconte des vrais gens et puis
les emmène où il veut
voilà on est sûr nist une histoire qui
pourrait être vrai en fait mais je sais
pas j'ai toujours cette sensation que ça
me correspond un peu comme je suis un
tire-au-flanc je vois pas voir trop
d'efforts à faire est à remarquer comme
on est tous gros dans le mobile est
vachement plus vite
non mais très sérieusement ce à quoi en
fait j'adore cette manière l'absurde le
politique comme en voilà le choix des
mots c'est quand même un auteur hors
faire vanessa vous connaissez très bien
son univers déjà ce que vous lui dites
oui quoi qu'il arrive
ah bah non non mais mais mais tout ce
qui m'a proposé c'est tellement des
cadeaux c'est tellement merveilleuse qui
puisqu'ils proposent à jouer j'avais
aucune envie tirs non il y a et puis way
son univers c'est exactement ce qu'est
ce qu'un étudier ces cetc des gens de
tous les jours qu'ils sont qui se
retrouvent dans des situations assez
exceptionnel donc c'est pour ça aussi
que son univers et touche tellement
parce que ont déjà et à son talent
d'écriture écriture qui est vraiment
très très haut et puis mais parce que
quand on voit ces films on on se
retrouve dans ses personnages et en même
temps les personnages du des choses qui
nous font rêver
alors vous êtes extrêmement drôle dans
le film on vous a jamais vu dans ce
registre
comment est ce que vous l'avez abordé ce
personnage ce qui m'inquiétait c'était
le bégaiement
parce que c'est un bégaiement tout petit
c'est vraiment pas facile à faire mais
oui ce personnage qui est bègue et qui
retrouve sa liberté
en juin la comédie parce que son
bégaiement disparaît jouer enfin c'est
gustave kervern qui est c'était vraiment
mais un coup de foudre avoir rencontre
quoi vraiment c'était merveilleux de
jouer face à lui et puis aussi avec avec
bruno podalydès qui je me prof de
théâtre
boc voilà j'ai une question pour vanessa
mais bon je pense que josé ça va vous
inspirez vous avez dit parce que je suis
principalement chanteuse et que la
musique est comme point réalisateur une
aventure qui prend beaucoup de temps
je ne vais vers le synode pour y vivre
des choses exceptionnelles puis
chanteuse dans le coeur dans l'âme ça
c'est sûr mais j'aimerais j'aimerais
d'être plus souvent actrice c 'est je
dépends du du des propositions des
autres je dépends de leur désir quoi
elle pas assez qui vous transporte east
room en grand mais je sais pas mais en
tout cas moi j'ai la sensation d'avoir
fait parfois d'avoir joué 5 minutes dans
la fuite dans un film pour montrer que
je suis pas que là pour pour jouer un
grand rôle moi en fait ce que j'aime
c'est jouer mais est dans un bon film
donc si ça dure deux minutes comme ça
j'y vais aucun problème et générait
plusieurs fois donc j'ai donc non enfin
oui peut-être principalement chanteuse
parce que ça s'apprend puis ce temps
d'être chanteur quand on fait un disque
une tournée ça nous prend des années de
notre vie mais acteur nippon le vengeur
en fait si tu fais de la musique pour
vendre des disques ou pour aller faire
du live en feu non c'est tout le temps
dit enfin écoutez moi je dirais que ces
multiples dans le sens où en fait il ya
ce côté aussi
c'est comme avoir des enfants tu sais tu
deviens le second rôle de ta vie non au
tac
et puis on a été chanteur ou rappeurs
enfin qu'est ce que c'est c'est un peu
se raconter c'est un peu voilà donc je
trouves tu vois ça on est dans la
continuité de quelque chose mon plasma
de l'un à l'autre ça fait partie de
l'état l'état quand on fait quand on
quand on chante une chanson on se met en
situation on est quoi qu'on dise quoi
qu'on raconte mais même si c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui tu écris en fait
on est sûrs tu peux vivre de ta personne
sur l'histoire et qu'est-ce que l'acting
c'est ça aussi ce que raconte aussi
parce que s'il ya vraiment cette
métaphore aussi de l'art qui permet de
dépasser ce que l'on est
votre personnage
on n'a pas assez moi c'est sûr vous
étiez frustré tous les deux de ne pas
avoir vraie scène ensemble c'est vous
auriez envie pour trouver sur un projet
relatif quand je vois vanessa m et comme
je suis un garçon contemplatif
je chante pas ça me suffit jamais dit ça
sur l'achat tablette ou non mais je fais
une interview donnée suisse et le soleil
en sus et madame madame ça c'est bon
alors on m'a dit que tu vas dire quoi
quel regard avez-vous sur joey starr a
memoir by toi mais parce que je pense
que je suis plus fan de ta musique que
toi de la mienne est donc oui je suis
pas sûr ça on a priori mais après peu
importe et cgc même avis et c'est toute
notre vie je veux pas qu au fus pas
forcément keith richards est très
mauvais
c'est ça les chansons même si on les
aime pas à l'époque elle est contournée
réécrite vingt ans plus tard elles ont
tellement fait partie de notre vie
qu'elle nomme gelé des chaussures avec
les news
c'était pas mal alors finalement cette
musique ne joue-t-elle vraiment pour
personne ah ben ça c'est une très jolie
questions posées dans le film en fait ça
il faut se la poser c'est moi je dirais
je dirigerai que quand je suis sortie du
film j'étais un peu dans le ruck
voilà deux strates sorti ce débit enfin
il m'a mis dans une humeur et une
demi-heure après en fait j'avais des
petites réminiscences et donc c'est une
musique qui joue pour tout le monde en
fait franchement il est bien ce joystick
pas qu'on l'ait sont durs merci je sais
je sais merci à saisir suis pas si
franchement regarde
[Musique]